the year was 2015. Lewis Joseph and
Sydney were like a lot of kids their age
which is to say 11 years old they
secretly stay up past their bedtime
watching scary videos on the internet
when their moms and dads think they're
sleeping they go to school every day and
daydream about all the fun things
they're going to do when that school
bell finally rings at the end of the day
and of course they play a lot and we
mean a lot of Minecraft whenever they're
not at school hanging out at the local
park and filming goofy Tick Tock videos
or watching those aforementioned scary
videos on the internet there's a good
chance that they'll be online together
logging a few extra hours building bases
digging big holes or playing survival
mode and seeing how long they can last
against the onslaught of mobs but
there's one particular Pursuit they have
while playing Minecraft together that
takes up the majority of their Play Time
One kihoric Quest that drives them
forward despite all the naysayers and
doubters tracking down and finding the
legendary Minecraft CreepyPasta entity
Herobrine for those who weren't around
on the internet back then Creepypastas
like Herobrine were all the rage like
any video game the new frontier of
Minecraft with all of its procedurally
generated Landscapes felt like it held
new Mysteries and Mysteries are equal
parts exciting and frightening after all
who really knows what's going on behind
a closed door Herobrine was a Minecraft
specific little urban legend stories
told of a default Minecraft skin with
eerily white eyes manifesting in the
game even in Solo matches and
terrorizing players one internet sleuth
who looked into the mystery of Herobrine
claimed it to be the haunted soul of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's Creator
Marcus person also known as notch in the
years since the legend first started
Notch himself has come forward and
disavowed the claim saying that in fact
he didn't even have a brother and never
had so the rumors were completely
baseless but as we here at the SCP
Foundation know the truth has never
gotten in the way of a good story so
Lewis Joseph and Sydney were happy to
remain Believers as long as they could
keep having fun chasing alleged digital
ghosts how could any of these boys know
that in the midst of their fun they'd
run into a real monster amidst
Minecraft's blocky distance it was a
school night like any other when they
made that first fateful Expedition it
was 7 15 pm and the boys were all in
their shared server Lewis had chicken
tenders Joseph had chicken nuggets and
Sydney who'd eaten his dinner earlier
than the others was snacking on a pack
of Skittles they'd all outfitted their
characters with full diamond armor with
diamond swords to match because Joseph
had somehow convinced the others that
diamonds were ghost proof he read it on
the internet he claimed together the
three boys had made themselves an
impressive Minecraft castle to be the
base of their Herobrine hunting
operations a safe haven surrounded by
high stone walls and MOB repelling
torches to keep them safe if ever they
got a little too spooked while playing
though playing was perhaps too mild a
word for it in the minds of these three
boys they were doing extremely important
investigative work after all if they
managed to actually find Herobrine
themselves they would be Creepypasta
Legends and wouldn't that be worth all
the hours upon hours of rigorous Mining
and crafting they'd been methodical in
their search scoping out different
corners of the map and canvassing them
together surging high and low and then
marking said area off their checklist it
was a level of consideration and thought
that their parents and teachers had long
wished the boys would put into their
home or school work but alas seeing as
none of the homework was find Herobrine
they really weren't that interest
today they were searching an area deep
in the misty forests in the dead of
night they fought off a few spiders and
sword-wielding skeletons thankfully no
creepers oh man and kept foraging on
into the darkness it's so creepy out
here it was set over his headset why do
we have to come out here at night it was
way more dangerous with all the mobs the
night is like the perfect time for
ghosts Sydney retorted you think a ghost
is gonna start hanging around in the
middle of the day no way it's got to be
a night man and Lewis simply could not
argue with such incredibly Sound Logic
they forged on doing their typical
methodical search for any phenomenon
that one might generously be able to
describe as Supernatural so you can only
imagine the excitement coursing through
them when Joseph discovered a strange
dark cave that looked as though it had
no business being there well each held
their own private reservations they all
knew what they needed to do go inside
and investigate as they entered the cave
a few strange realizations occurred to
them such as the fact that there were
seemingly no mobs down here the cave in
the dead of night surely there should be
some enemies right plus the typical
lighting implements like torches and
lanterns didn't seem to offer the same
kind of Illumination that they normally
would it was almost like the darkness
was more oppressive here more tangible
there was undeniably something Eerie
about the whole setup that much couldn't
be denied you guys see anything Lewis
asked no Joseph said sounding oddly
cautious as though he sent something
strange was on the horizon something
that perhaps these boys shouldn't see
yeah I haven't seen anything either
Sydney chimed in maybe we should Joseph
screamed and the two others turned their
Minecraft Avatars to look at him
Joseph's character had bumped into
something some stranger in the cave an
NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the
purposefully Lo-Fi blocky world of
Minecraft it seemed to have a dark body
with a canid skull-like face bearing a
pair of milky white eyes that seemed to
stare off into nothingness was this
another mob maybe something added in the
latest patch if so why wasn't it
attacking what is that thing Lewis asked
over his headset I don't know Joseph
replied it's so creepy though suddenly a
message appeared on the screen as though
it had been typed and sent by another
player a player with the username Mal o
the message read hey that isn't very
nice you shouldn't judge on appearances
kid that certainly gave them pause so
many things about this didn't make sense
it had all the Hallmarks of an NPC but
apparently it understood their voices
and could send messages it clearly
wasn't actually another player in a
conventional sense but it didn't attack
like your typical mob none of the boys
could really make sense of what they
were dealing with here are you a hacker
Sydney asked no mallow typed back I'm
just lonely and a long way from home
it's nice to have your company down here
though I don't get visitors often have
you heard of Herobrine Lewis asked
mellow typed back is he a friend of
yours you should introduce him to me I
love making new friends the three boys
were in some regards rather mature and
polite for their ages and so remained
civil with this bizarre mysterious
figure it was curious and inquisitive
asking them questions about their school
lives and their friends it did seem
earnestly happy for their company so it
didn't give any of them the sense that
it was a threat as night Drew on in the
boy's respective parents told them it
was time to log off and get some shut
eye mellow finally typed I've really
enjoyed hanging out with you kids come
back and visit me again tomorrow if you
don't I'll come visit you instead none
of the kids picked up on the probably
rather obvious stranger danger Vibes of
this message and instead they went to
bed excited and curious the next day
they met up on the playground for a kind
of State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the
night before do you think it has
anything to do with Herobrine Lewis
asked forget Herobrine Sydney replied
posting gasp from the two others all the
other people have Herobrine we have
something better something only we've
discovered we've got mallow later that
night Joseph who was probably the most
studious of the group tried to do a
little background research on Malo
everything seemed to turn up dead ends
aside from one slightly shitty looking
app called Malo version 1.0.0 it's
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again mallow is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but just after a few hours of mallow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember
remember the more you participate the
more Malo will engage you your
experience is completely up to you
absolutely no ads enjoy weird so unless
the thing they encountered on Minecraft
was some kind of weird viral marketing
campaign for the app it was probably
just a coincidence maybe it was a
popular character from Japan or
something by the way for the next
several days the boys honored their
promise they'd visit Malo in the cave
every night and chat trying to tactfully
get more information out of it though
the best they could get on the entity's
origin was the cryptic statement I'm not
usually here but everyone wants a
vacation once in a while don't they we
can't just spend our whole life on a
phone they'd become so acclimated to
Malo over the days that they forgot what
the entity had said to them the very
first day they met come back and visit
me again tomorrow if you don't I'll come
visit you instead but on the day that
they didn't come and visit mellow
because Miss Grayson had sent a
particularly challenging piece of
English homework they received a
frightening reminder that very night
they all started receiving strange texts
on their phones as you can probably
expect they were all photographs each
and every one depicting some regular
haunt that the boys all like to frequent
with one addition malo's grinning skull
face hiding somewhere in the image like
some kind of demented parody of where's
Waldo the strangeness of this new
development left all the boys shaken and
they hopped back onto Minecraft as
quickly as possible to go find and talk
to Mellow in its cave however this time
the cave was empty and Mala was nowhere
to be seen But the text still didn't
stop they'd come in so frequently with
Malo getting closer to home literally in
each one the boys thought about telling
their parents but would their parents
believe them they probably lump Mal Owen
with the same Tall Tales of childhood
imagination as Herobrine and write it
off as bored kids playing a prank even
though in this case it was anything but
more photos arrived and these ones Mal o
was right outside each of the children's
homes lurking watching in some of the
photos they could see themselves in the
windows going about their evening
business having no idea of the creature
lurking just outside none of the boys
felt like playing Minecraft that night
it wasn't fun anymore instead they shut
themselves up in their rooms closed and
locked their windows and pulled down the
blinds after checking under the beds
with flashlights of course but still
more photos came in all depicting mellow
getting closer and closer and closer
right about the time they were wondering
whether the scratching on the outside of
their bedroom door was real or just
figment of their imagination another
dark irony had occurred to them all this
time trying to find something
Supernatural and in the very end
something Supernatural had instead found
them want an anomaly of your own check
out scpswag.com for high quality SCP
merch now go check out
scp-1471 Mal o version 1.0.0 and what if
scp-1471 Mal o was put inside
scp-914 for more marvelous Mal o Madness